[Music]
in a new interview wheel of fortune host
pat sajak
said that he and vanna white used to get
drunk before taping the show
that's what he said
yeah yeah he said they used to get drunk
before taping the show and uh i thought
that's crazy i checked out some footage
i believe him
yes check out this old clip from wheel
of fortune
the last time i was in vietnam the
government said man it was a different
situation uh yeah
and now it's great to see uh
that going outside was a beautiful city
even then and uh it's great to see all
that you know we're on it you and i are
in some of these markets you know they
have these other versions of the show
but in a lot of caribbean and
in central south america i mean we're on
and
run in mexico around honduras and haiti
and
colombia and costa rica
[Applause]
they never even got to a contestant on
that episode
he listed six countries and passed out
unbelievable though he also sajak
apparently also there was uh one show
where just beforehand he uh he did some
lsd
i i couldn't believe it but look
a t please yeah one team
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hi
[Applause]
[Music]
that brain dance is the way i do in a
club